siamo su alla save your save your culo
in qualche modo lo so è un gioco molto
insiemi piacenza convenuta altro
comitato compare st mano vernio game
allora credo che sia una demo
teoricamente non è normale però devi
stare calmo subito perché se uno stacco
gioco happy with the space 2 song e il
canzonatorio è stato tutto colpa di quel
sogno bisogna dargli un'occhiata in giro
è diamoci questo occhiata in giro ma
video ottenere i controlli la polizia
che toglie listone sono tre tasti come è
molto sia perché è tipo come il father
un pony molto figo peccato che sia una
demo con il menù che sta sempre qua
porca [ __ ] era cosa già bravo bravo
così si montano i video e la taglia
taglia la toglie la perché è scomparsa
porca [ __ ] che cos'è questo odore e mi
sa che c'è una porta aperta con del
ketchup rovesciato e che ciò perché non
posso passare perché bloccata da una
pila di pietro si sposta attenzione però
aspetta prima di spostarlo vediamo non
di qua perché prima vedere la bellissima
stanza questa
questo non è un gioco che mi prendo meno
male che ho salvato o meno male che ho
salvato all'inizio del gioco va bene
allora andiamo a ok perfetto era
esattamente quello che volevo fare senza
averlo fatto me l'ha fatto va bene è
veramente figo studio sembra fatto
veramente bene comunque patisca ci provo
fatto bene prendo il martello e lodo in
testa quello che sta dentro la porta
sì lo prendo sono thor gol di m
comunque io le lo sgabello che lo
porterei perché sono alta un metro e 56
si sa mai
anyway l'esca prison a2 giorno questo
sta stava ascoltando la musica sbagliata
è morto
mi fa piacere che laghi con l reaction
prova bene bimbo stai bene non sta solo
morendo dissanguato sul muro per carità
di dio non presente sul quale si è
spuntata un'altra volta sembra che come
se sì con che sembra morta poverina va
bene
l'unica job in disordine giovine and
would you like the clocks hackett
pensare i dati swatch a è una campo a
campanella va bene ho tratto una
campanella va bene le scopo non
chiedetemi ma va bene basta a coach e
l'altra ventola penalizzato qua non
c'entro più dunque chi cazzo sei fermati
o diventerai presto un mostro non è vero
che senso
[Musica]
mica ragazzi ma è meglio di outlast cioè
veramente ma cosa sto vedendo salve
visto che è successo un casino
prendi la tessera insanguinata certo
armate che tra può diventare un mostro
ma cosa che succede alla faccia degli
esperimenti questo abbiamo capito c'è
del sangue un po ovunque questo
l'abbiamo capito la porta al identity
card è sporca non può essere
riconosciuto che lavarla nel lavandino a
il prigioniero che sta nella c1 a questa
cella e cieco ma molto sensibile al
suono quando quello della prigione della
cella a due fa solo con la campanella
lui mostra un sacco di aggressività
quindi fate attenzione che devo fare la
campanella da salvato la campanella da
sabato faccio che uso il lavandino
chiama usate più di quelli che si spiega
l'acqua paura
sarà una partita anche qua mori che è un
piacere
fa ridere se posso entra possa entrare
qua dentro e stare zitto tipo la porta
aperta
porca [ __ ]
era lanciata perfetto oddio è successo e
se non va bene non ho capito niente ma
ok
posso usare il martello uso lo affascina
è spaccato della cella di fianco
ma ordinato il cibo che sono le 840 o
salve credo che lei avviare dei seri
problemi di litigio con il suo letto a
una piazza io salgo la partita comunque
al di là di sta roba corridoio e abbiamo
giustamente sono passato attraverso la
porta perché il muro e sfondato il
kraken forse perché c'è nulla salve che
è provvista sa vado a destra io con
corridoio 2
andiamo nel corridoio 1 che dite siamo
arrivati in un attenzione che la cena
hicks brutta
beh voglio solo vedere cosa succede fino
a indovinare mi tirano dentro il letto
oppure dalla porta esce con un tentacolo
di piglia
ho scritto io sto gioco perché li so io
le cose niente quella fare lì da voi
dove in qualche modo trigger harlow no
non ho ben capito cede sangue fa un
cristo santo bene
ha salutato la sua carta sbagliata porca
[ __ ] che palle
devo allora devo devo attirarne uno dei
due e devo andare nel corridoio scaffali
schiacciare dalla loggia scommettete che
schiacciano
ma chi cazzo è che lanciasse rocce
allora ha trovato un magma ha trovato
l'uomo in italiano braccio di uomo pazzo
rilanciamo il braccio di uomo pazzo qua
forse per metterlo qua se devi stare
calmo lo zio calmo blog ed memotech vero
presa ciao vorrei farvi salvare quelli
del dolce là dentro
aido molto going to display ma per non
c'è datazione posso facevano cosa di
sotto tono che ansia o saleh sono
normale non essere paura in oro e che mi
stanno seguendo di sopra i mostri stanno
correndo in questa faciliti proprio
adesso devi scappare più la gente
possibile c'è un ascensore in questa
sala come poi saperci tanto sono
ricercatori e faccio ricerche sono
scelse non conoscere conoscere tutto di
questo
dimmi perché sono qua mi dispiace posso
soltanto dire che per qualche strano
esperimento e non è non è il momento vai
a prendere l'ascensore ok riguardo te
devo cercare se ci sono altri
sopravvissuti salvare le persone è
l'unica cosa che posso fare adesso capi
meno madonna questo è un esperimento
uscito malissimo e aggiungo anche che è
morto tizio porca [ __ ] non è vero ma
dai ma che sfiga porca vi si è messo
davanti ma dai ma non ci che è
difficilissimo se che lo fa credo che la
porta che sia aperta credo forse qua
sotto cioè nel senso questo a questa
parte era chiusa prima
porca vacca sì sì la grangia fatto
sapere stazione five amico avere
e durato zero secondi il lato torchia è
sì o no chiama impossibile
ok oddio l'ascensore caccia al giorno di
io sto salendo sto salendo a miglia che
ansia e la madonna
salve io sono io quello di save me
nola per pazzesca frondista river plate
ma che figata di gioco
sei bellissimo web e spettacolare ma che
esca ragazzo veronese aiuto ragazzi cosa
semplice da circoletto è un bel mi piace
anche la risorsa perché come fate sempre
nella descrizione sensato si schieri e
noi come sempre ci vediamo hanno
proseguito per ragazzi
[Musica]